hello everyone and welcome to what could
be the most important game of the second
half of the candidates tournament the
leader yanni pony she faces fabiana
carwana fabi has the white pieces in
this game and if you uh forgot what the
standings were these are the standings
after the previous round so nipple
leading with six points and five
trailing with five points with nakamura
on four and a half and rapport on four
uh ding doo doo and furuja still to
score uh their first victory in the
tournament so if fabi can grab a full
point uh here in this game against nepo
that will bring them uh six to six and
we will have uh an incredible race uh
until the end of the tournament but uh
you know nepo is still undefeated it's
not going to be easy but fabio will of
course try and as he plays e4 here uh of
course we know that the petrov defense
is uh going to be on the board so e5
knight to f3 and knight to f6 the petrov
defense is on the board and fabi
challenges the petrol if he doesn't
decline it with knights to c3 like we've
seen in the previous video knight
captures an e5 d6 knight back to f3 and
knight captures an e4 we have d for d5
and bishop to d3 so the standard
classical attack against the petrov and
what can fabi do to
uh to sort of even challenge nipple here
to maybe create some sort of an
imbalance where he can maybe play for a
win because both uh caruana and nip
nippon she prepared the petrov defense
for the world championship match against
magnus carlsen uh for as you know for to
be one of the
weapons that are going to be used and
they both know it extremely well so
bishop to d6
we have castles by fabi and now castles
by nipple we have c for c6 and now rook
to e1 this is already uh starting to
deviate a little bit here the the main
moves are knight to c3 queen to c2 and c
captures on d5 all of these moves are
with the idea of weakening the knight on
e4 and so is the move that fabi plays
rook to e1 so it's the fourth most
popular move in this position already
you can see that fabi is starting to
deviate bishop to f5 and queen to b3 the
bishop left the defense of the b7 pawn
so we are attacking it nepa defends it
and here comes a move that was uh well
it was played only once in 2006 between
two 1700 players or rather one was 1651
was 1700 and that move is knight to h4
so it was played only once
uh and this is what fabi uh brought
at the challenge nipple with uh so uh
you can be sure that he he
you know dug very very deep and hard to
define this one usually you just go
knight to c3 or you grab more space with
c5 where we play bishop to e3 but knight
the h4 this is a new one and it already
uh you know asks us the question what do
you do with the bishop here do you just
uh allow us to capture it because then
you lose the bishop pair do you go to g6
then we're gonna uh maybe capture and
you're gonna play age captors or do you
bring the bishop back and this is
exactly what nepal does so already here
we have a completely new game in that
game that i've mentioned the captures
and c4 was played but here after bishop
to e6 already on movie 11 we have a
completely new game
uh and okay queen to c2 fabi now puts
more pressure on the knight here and
knight the a6 just continuing
development definitely makes sense you
want to play a knight to be for put
pressure on the queen and the bishop
here and uh you could sort of uh win
material here because if you play bishop
captures knight here d captures and
let's say queen captures yes you want a
piece but rook f38 and you're gonna have
a lot of problems because okay now you
can move the queen but the rook here is
also on the e file it's a it's a very
very tricky position for example queen
to c2
or something there are many many ideas
here for black like bishop to f5 attacks
the queen attacks the rook and although
you can trade for example captures
captures now your queen is hanging and
there's the threat of checkmate so it's
a very very unpleasant
unpleasant situation you have to defend
for example queen d2 even bishop the
seat you can be played and this is just
very very annoying and of course you
don't want to allow stuff like that so
you cannot win material here but you can
play a3 and say okay your knight on a6
will look a little bit weird
and it will take some time for you to
reintroduce it into the game but nepo
just plays f5 uh he he maybe doesn't
know this exact position but he knows
the similar ones and um f5 is a useful
move in in most of them so see captures
on d5 c captures and knight the c3 and
here we have rook 8 c8 by uh by nepo uh
also interesting here as fabi definitely
prepared for this as well is knight back
to b8 point is that after f3 which of
course uh
fabi wants to play in all lines we are
just going to ignore him we're going to
play knight to c6 we're going to
sacrifice the knight here because if you
accept this then f captures uh we're
going to play knight captures on d4
attack the white queen and after the
queen moves f captures an e4 yes we've
sacrificed the piece but we've grabbed
so many pawns we have this massive
center here we have the bishop pair
black is the one to be to be preferred
here so basically what you would have to
do is not capture the knight but play
something like the bishop to e3 then
we're gonna trade captures captures and
uh the game continues so most likely
this is what what fabi had in mind black
is perfectly fine here
but of course uh that is to be expected
with this uh weird knight to h4 move so
it's a it's a gambit whether it pays off
or not uh we'll see so rook eight to c8
and now pawn to f3 finally attacking
this knight and this is the first moment
where nipple really started uh
using his clock and he did not move the
knight you could move the knight and
it's perfectly fine for example you
could play knight captures on c3 but he
goes bishop to e7 he says that knight is
still looking weird there and i'm gonna
use it um to my advantage uh and fabi
just instantly played pawn to g3 saying
this is all well within my preparation
which can also be uh confirmed by the
situation on the clocks fabi is an hour
and 55 minutes on the clock here where
is nipple already dropped to one minute
one hour and 15 minutes on the clock so
knight back to d6 and this is the move
that fabi
did not check or maybe maybe he did
check it but it's um and not the one you
would expect here uh because probably
what fabi had in mind is uh well if
bishop captures an h4 then white really
has nothing to worry about yes you ruin
a white spawn structure but after knight
captures on c3b captures there's this
very nice queen to c6 move and you don't
have to uh worry all that much okay you
can't go after this because the bishop
is hanging but uh you know it's a nice
position bishop to f4 and the fabi is
enjoying this position so it doesn't
matter that the the king side is
shattered this is perfectly fine for
white so that's one thing and the other
one is after this g3 move the absolute
best for nepo is bishop to f6 and this
is also probably what fabi had checked
where he will win the knight here f
captures f captures and bishop captures
an a6 ruin uh the the queen side uh
bishop captures on d4 with chuck bishop
to e3 for example captures characters
and b captures on e6 and you get this
position where again everything is
perfectly fine but um
you know it's only if nipple spots all
of this so this would be the absolute
best that the engine has to recommend
but never plays knight to d6 and this is
now where fabi uh
first starts uh spending some time still
uh fabi almost two hours on the clock
like an hour and 55 minutes and nipple
already down to an hour
and here just queen the a4 offering a
queen trade and this is again very very
annoying phobia spent some 30 minutes
for this move but it is the absolute top
move recommended by the engine and the
problem is if you trade queens which
seems like a good idea for black because
you you know you got surprised out of
the opening you may maybe you'd want to
draw with the black pieces
it's very very hard to play for example
king to f7 you're going to play bishop
captures on a6 b captures and now knight
to c5 put pressure on this bishop here
and there is no way to defend the bishop
you can't defend it you can't move it
anywhere so the only thing left is to
give up the exchange with the rook
captures here and the d captures on c5
uh leaving for a very very complicated
end game for example knight to c4 and
now whether you're gonna play b4 or
you're gonna move the knight and then
bring the knight over over to here to
put more pressure on the e6 pawn uh so
all depends on what black plays but fabi
would very much enjoy playing this
position but nepo does not give him this
opportunity and he goes for bishop to f6
another very interesting line is rook to
c6 just uh stopping the queen trade but
also adding the the rook here so you
don't have to mess up your pawn
structure and now if bishop captures
we're going to play bishop captures on
h4 if g captures rook captures here and
now okay you can trade but now
everything is perfectly fine you have an
intact pawn structure on the queen side
uh fabi's king's side is ruined a little
bit so i it's it would be very much
playable but okay here we have bishop to
f6 and this is basically where the game
truly begins and where fabi will be
trying to get some chances so queen
captures on d7 bishop captures he goes
for a queen trade knight captures and e5
and the bishop captures on d4 with king
to g2 and now rook c the e8 as fabi's uh
threatening uh knight e7 check to pick
up the rook on c7 so rook c to e8 and
now bishop to f4 putting pressure on the
knight here and never just plays knight
to c5 uh so attacking the bishop ended
the traits um
although they could work in white's
favor they they really don't here
because if you just start trading knight
cap bishop captures knight captures on
d3 bishop captures nf8 knight captures
any one comes with check and after the
king moves we're gonna play king
captures an f8 and you're just up a full
piece of course this is completely
winning for nipple now
uh so after knight to c5 we have knight
to e7 check uh makes sense as you are
also preparing to capture the the knight
here but this is what nepo found king to
f7 just playing spectacular
defensive ideas and the problem for
fobby is that now fabi is lower on the
clock he has 37 minutes on the clock nip
of some 40 minutes on the clock and what
is what is this sorcery can can't we
just uh you know do something about it
this knight here uh what's what's what's
happening here uh well if you go for
this bishop captures on d6 it's not
really all that impressive as your
bishop here is also hanging knight
captures here attacks the rook and we
kind of go back into the line that we've
already discussed so here after king to
f7 fobby played uh
uh bishop captures an f on f5 but the
actual strongest idea is bishop to f1
looks weird but now that you see it of
course you you believe it as the rook is
coming to d1 and there are all of these
targets on the d file
it would be very very annoying to defend
this with absolute perfect play you will
find knight the c8 but still it's not
going to be pretty knight captures an f5
bishop captures on b2 rook attacks
bishop bishop captures on f5 now knight
captures on f5 and rook captures an e1
rook captures and now rook to d8 you get
this position uh where okay it's equal
material but uh
white will always be better due to the
active bishop pair bishop c for check
and it's already very very unpleasant
for that black king king to fade rookie
2 not allowing uh
any and any uh rook left from black also
putting pressure on the bishop for
example bishop f6 h4 then g for g5 g uh
the the pawns just start marching
forward and the king is in a very very
tight spot here so this would be the way
to put the pressure on nipple's position
but fabi misses this he's uh already
getting very low on time he plays bishop
captures on f5 and now fabi has only 19
minutes on the clock nepo has 40 minutes
on the clock and there are still 16 more
moves to be made to reach time control
uh and here just knight captures uh on
e5 and this is again the correct way to
play if you go for rook captures on e7
uh then of course bishop captures and d7
is just deadly even if rook captures an
e1 we just play rook captures on e1 and
now bishop captures an f5 uh bishop
captures an f8 and now bishop to e6 we
said save the bishop but now bishop
captures on c5 bishop captures and you
can see that white is of course
completely winning here white is up upon
and also up the exchange so uh knight
captures on f5 is definitely to be
preferred here which is what happens in
the game now comes knight captures on f5
bishop captures an f5 knight captures on
f5 and a whole lot of captures here rook
captures on e1 rook captures an e1 in
the knight to d3 and after this capture
fist and nipple finds the absolute
strongest idea attacks the rook attacks
the bishop and there isn't all that much
for fabric to do here that's the problem
uh rook to e7 although it looks
spectacular doesn't really do anything
because we're just going to play uh king
to f6 and now you can't go for the
bishop as we capture the rook and it
bishop to d6 which seems like a kind of
a good idea
there's rook d8
and
nothing works here for white really
knight captures on the e4 rook captures
on d6 you can capture on g7 or rather on
g7
uh because if now king captures knight
to f5 check will pick up the rook and if
rook captures on d4 then we go into this
rook captures on h7 knight captures on
b2 rook captures on b7 fabi would have
uh
three pawns for the night but it is not
a serious attempt at winning or rather
you could play this like if your life
absolutely depended on it it's the best
chance you would get but it's also the
best chance to completely drop out of
the
out of the race if you give nippo a full
point here so rook to e4 let's not
forget fab is also a low on the low on
time bishop captures on b2 now bishop to
e3 not allowing this trade bishop
captures an a3 bishop captures an a7 and
now rook to a8 attacking the bishop here
bishop to d4 and the bishop back to f8
uh and here rook to e2 by fabi uh here
fabi could force uh a draw here with
with bishop captures on g7 but he is
down to to two minutes and he doesn't
doesn't find the instant save for
example rookie 7 check king to f6 and
now rook captures on g7 again you give
up the knight for for some pawns here
rook captures on b7 king g6 now you have
these three pawns here for for the night
or rather two points for the night but
still it's a it's a draw uh but okay
rook to a2 was played giving nepo the
opportunity to now maybe play for
advantage and he does g6 now bishop
captures on g7 is no longer an option
and fabi has to find a unique set of
moves he only has two minutes to play
eight moves to reach time control
otherwise he's just busted so knights to
e3 let's not forget nipple has the pass
b pawn uh rook to d8 attacks the bishop
and bishop b6 attacks the rook here
so uh here fabi of course knows how to
hold this perfectly perfectly well uh
but you know one uh relatively weird
move from nepo could could go a long way
as fabi is extremely low on clock on the
clock so rook to d6 attacks the bishop
knight to c4 the rook to e6 is coming so
you don't want to allow this and you
also have to defend your bishop so
knights to c4 makes sense rook to c6
attacks the knight and now rook to e4 we
have bishop to g7 and now pawn to f4
rook to e6 offering a rook trade and
king to f3 now knight to the e1 check by
nipple king the e3 knights the c to
check king to f3 and now knight to the
e1 check and here by playing knight to
e1 check both players have now reached
mu 40 time control has been reached
additional time has been received and he
was in this position on move 40 that
fabiana caruana and yanipon she agreed
to a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here
it is equal material
uh yeah and of course both of them are
are
well aware that and
you know
one will not defeat the other in this
position and it's better to uh you know
now look for look for a fight uh on
another day uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it a really really
a tough one uh fabi really did well to
spot that i mean to to prepare this
night stage for move like i said uh this
movie is nowhere to be found in engine
recommendations it has been played only
once in like i said in a low level game
in 2006
and this is what he had to come up with
to try and surprise nepo in the petrol
because nepo is is immortal basically in
the petrol of defense and um uh well uh
this was maybe one way uh to ask some
questions and to post some problems
about uh nepo you know uh he even though
fabi is the one who surprised nepo in
the end it was fabi who was in time
trouble and i mean it's just incredible
how how quickly uh nipple adapts to
these new positions and just you know
finds his way out of out of all the
chaos really incredible stuff with the
black pieces uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it nepo uh retains
his one point lead ahead of fabi going
into round ten so we'll see we'll see
what happens next uh i would like to
thank david kimura stephen mcneill abby
dalby is the one daniel schmidt and
ultimate poker coaching for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day